We Begin tonight with Fascism and how it
takes root Donald Trump is back in
business he's here whether you like it
or not and uh yes he's Hitler and a
fascist and all that stuff check out
this was I'm not going to show you all
three minutes of it just a little bit of
Joy Reed starting her show yesterday and
I'd also like everyone to focus on her
hair because I don't think it's natural
and we begin tonight with Fascism and
how it takes root now it isn't usually a
dramatic storm the palace coup like we
saw on January 6th it's more often a
deal a bargain between the wouldbe
dictator and the establishment both
political and media who believe that
wielding actual political power will
take him it's usually what we often it
it will actually will actually tame him
I should say it's actually what we often
get wrong about fascism in describing
the connections between interwar Europe
and the present day us scholar John Gans
writes quote we have this image in our
heads of the fascist rise to power that
comes from fascist prop propaganda but
it is much more political than that in
her viiew of gans's new book in the
American Prospect Rick pearlstein also
Notes The crucial role of the quote
responsible conservatives who made their
peace with the strong man believing he
could be controlled pearlstein recalls
Germany's Vice Chancellor France bonen
the architect of the 1933 Coalition that
made Adolf Hitler the chancellor when
the people around papen voiced their
concerns about putting Hitler in power
papen said said in 2 months we'll have
pushed Hitler so far into the corner
that he'll
squeal there's also the phenomenon of
Elites who become supplicants of the
fascist leader forgetting they ever had
any concerns at all remember what
Lindsey Graham tweeted back in 2016 when
Trump was still an outlier in the party
I do quote if we nominate Trump we will
get destroyed and we will deserve it
when Trump won the White House anyway
Graham got busy reducing himself to a
magga foot stol in the US Senate
proximity to power will will do that
like Trump Hitler was also viewed as a
clown a goon who would be who could be
kept in
line and then there are the
accommodations that the media makes with
autocracy in November 1922 the New York
Times gave its readers their first
glimpse of Hitler it was a profile of
the fascist leaders early rise in
Bavaria and Germany that got a key Point
very wrong asserting that quote Hitler's
anti-Semitism was not so violent or
Genuine as it
sounded before he rose to power Hitler
staged a coup known as the beer hall
push it was a coup that failed sound
familiar Hitler went to prison for it
but the failed coup set the stage for
Nazi Germany and when he was freed from
prison just over a year after the failed
PCH the times offered this unfortunate
and incorrect assessment that Hitler had
been tamed by prison the next year mine
comp was published so much of this
sounds familiar and believe me I wish
didn't the same thing happened with a
lot of other autocrats The Establishment
thinks they can be controlled and poof
they're stuck with them the thought that
these men Could Be Tamed is what we're
seeing right now in the presidential
election year where politicians
journalists and voters speak of a
dangerous person getting reigned in once
back in power and those who are
legitimately afraid of this outcome are
being quiet about it last week the
annual meeting of the world economic
Forum in davo Switzerland brought
together so Sarah what's the deal with
her hair no just kidding um wait can I
answer that it's
cult yeah what is it it is cultural
appropriation yes from
Karen that's Karen here cancel that
woman for God's sakes the actually
though the of course okay Hitler fascism
all that stuff Sarah do you think it you
can see them busting out the same
Playbook again I mean we've been through
this this is what you guys did that led
to the rise of the guy in the first
place you're doing it again it's leading
to the rise this time and by the way you
guys are the ones that are trying to
take him off the ballot and hang him up
in court and do sort of fascy things do
you think it's going to work again I
don't I don't I don't especially at a
time maybe uh if we had not lived
through three years of Joe Biden but
we're living through a time where you
know it's so cute when they throw out
the term fascism while their own party
are you know uh trying to imprison their
own political opponents while their own
party are throwing people uh into prison
for decades because you know they put
their feet up on Nancy Pelosi's desk
while they are you know tar pro-life
protesters for peacefully protesting uh
the act of abortion I mean you have
really reprehensible people in charge I
call them the Biden regime for a reason
so it's just really cute to hear this it
may have worked if we hadn't been living
at a time where the average American
doesn't care what you call someone else
what they care about is how much it
costs to fill up their gas tank how much
it costs when they buy groceries at the
grocery store uh how much their mortgage
rate has increased their P their
interest rates and that's what the
average American am is seeing and
feeling and I just don't think name
calling is going to work this time and I
will also add Dave I know you guys know
this I mean I know that you saw it but
if it was Ronda santis they would have
called him the same things they were
already preparing to do that they were
already throwing in the seeds to plant
so that they could start calling Ronda
santis Hitler and a fascist and
alt-right and all of the same things
that they call Donald Trump it's all an
illusion none of it is real and they
know it's not and I just don't think
it's going to work this time no they
were prepping the the disantis thing
they were basically calling him Hitler
with the calculator like at least the
orange guy's an idiot but this guy knows
what he's doing it's going to be even
worse mice what what do we do about this
like information gap of the type of
person that watches MSNBC which of
course is dwindling numbers and we get
the fight between Legacy Media and
online media but that there still are
millions and millions of people that buy
this stuff and they're they're living in
an alternate universe and we got to save
them or forget about them or
institutionalize them what do we do
you're the one who wants to continue
being in a country with them I want to
live in free Texas I'm not even kidding
there's no getting through them by your
own admission uh here's the other thing
let's take for let's just take them
arguments seriously for a second if you
regard Trump as a hitler-like figure and
your strategy last time didn't stop him
it is incumbent on you to do everything
in your power to think of a new strategy
to take this guy on because we're
looking at the destruction of one's
country and genocide but the fact that
they're just saying the same things over
and over means they're not particular I
believe that these corporate journalists
are scared when the first one leaves the
country you know I mean if Hitler's
coming into Power even just the threats
so many people not just Jewish people
like I got to get the heck out of Dodge
because this is getting really scary
really fast they're not selling their
houses and you know uh Cape cot or
whatever they don't care because it's
not going to affect them they're full of
they're completely full of crap uh I do
think though um to the point about the
hair Karen is the swing voter in this
country yeah and Karen is it's going to
be kind kind of hard to convince Karen
to vote for someone who is a felon so
this idea that you know it's going to be
a cakewalk for Trump is not at all
accurate they got him out of the White
House in 2020 so the concept that like
well it's just going to be a given that
in
2024 uh you know after three years
people are going to go vote for Trump
that's not obvious to me at all and it's
not all obvious to me that Biden's going
to be the nominee because it's going to
be very easy and I've said this before
hold on if they pull Biden they can put
in Hillary and Hillary had already
gotten Millions more votes than Trump in
the wrong States but I'd rather start
out with someone who you people have
voted for before who have millions more
votes and now it's just a matter of
accounting and putting the votes right
right place with Nome as the VP so they
don't have to defend the California
record that would be a very strong
ticket for the Democrats and then she
wouldn't have to defend Biden she could
just throw Biden's record on the bus I'm
with you that it's that Suburban kind of
white woman or these disaffected libs
that have kind of woke up over the last
few months that those are the only
people who might move and the issue with
Trump is that they don't seem to want
Trump